foreign
[Music]
Arnold and I'm in the department of
Integrative biology and Physiology at
UCLA today I'm going to talk about sex
chromosome factors
that contribute to sex differences and
disease
so there are really Four Points in
today's lecture first of all in mammals
there's an inherent sexual inequality in
the expression of X and Y genes in every
tissue of the body and these cause sex
differences in these different tissues
but we've not known what are the genes
on the X and the Y chromosome that cause
these Effects by and large especially I
mean especially outside the gonads
we approach the study of these of this
question through the use of two animal
models two mouse models the four chord
genotypes and the XY star model
and these Studies have led in the last
few years to the identification of two x
genes
KDM 6A and KDM 5C and a y-link gene uty
as primary agents
causing sex differences in different
tissues
our approach to the study of sex
differences
really stems from a theoretical
viewpoint the old Theory from the last
century was
that the inherent sex difference in the
X and the Y sex chromosomes plays out
first
in the gonads
individuals that have a y chromosome and
the sry gene develop testes and those
without the Y chromosom develop ovaries
and so the sex chromosomes determine the
kind of gonad and that's the first step
of sexual differentiation called sex
determination as in it's a genetic step
the second step is called sexual
differentiation and it's hormone
hormonal because the gonads create
different uh different hormones either
testicular hormones or ovarian hormones
and these act throughout the body to
cause sex differences in traits this
model is in the textbooks and is still
taught today a lot of people still think
this way
but the model is inaccurate because sex
differences develop before the gonads do
and they develop after the gonads do for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
secretions of the gonads
so we've proposed another idea another
model
which is that that the the first and
foremost sex difference which is genetic
which happens in the zygote the
individual is either XX or x y
that yes that plays out to cause gonadal
differentiation as in the old model and
hormonal effects on throughout the body
which are quite potent but in addition
these differences in the sex chromosomes
play out in other dishes of the body and
these are called sex chromosome effects
and they cause sex differences in
physiology and disease as well
but we've known about the hormonal
effects
um really for 60 to 100 years and so the
hormones have been well studied and we
know what they are the different
testicular and ovarian secretions that
make sex differences happen elsewhere
are testosterone
progesterone and anti-malarian hormone
um but we don't know which are the genes
on the sex what are the primary agents
of sexual differentiation coming from
the sex chromosome via the sex
chromosome effects
these really haven't been known but as
I'll mention they've been uh recently
identified at least the first few we
don't know them all we have known for
some years what classes of genes on the
sex chromosomes might be causing sex
differences
and
um I've written about four classes there
might be five or six or seven different
classes
but the primary classes are number one y
genes are which are present only in XY
cells will cause X Y cells to be
different from XX cells
the second category is the dosage of X
genes that having two exchromosomes
inherently makes X dosage higher in
those cells than in XY cells
but this x dosage different of course is
mitigated or in in for most X genes One
X chromosome is turned off in the XX
cells by X inactivation
and so the dose of X genes is made more
equivalent in XX and XY cells
now there's a whole class of genes that
escape X inactivation and therefore
still are expressed higher in XX than x
x y and we'll be emphasizing those
uh today a third class that we'll
mention in passing is that the parental
imprint on X genes differs in xx and XY
cells because
x x cells receive both a maternal and a
paternal imprint but X Y cells only
receive a maternal imprint and I won't
mention it for this talk any other
classes of sex difference so today we're
going to emphasize this x does a
difference
that some X genes are expressed higher
than in xx and XY cells
the model that we begin with for
studying sex chromosome effects is
called the four core genotypes model
developed by Paul Burgoyne and Robin
level badge at the National Institute
for medical research in London
and this model is particularly good
because the you can compare XX and X Y
mice that have the same kind of gonad as
we see in the next couple of slides
a typical male on the left has the sry
gene the test is the terminating gene on
the Y chromosome and it and that male
makes two kinds of sperm either y
carrying or X carrying sperm whereas in
the four chord genotypes model the sry
is not on the Y chromosome it's been
lost through a spontaneous
deletion
and the sry gene is inserted as a
transgene ontus chromosome 3.
so this animal can make X sperm either
with sry or without sry
and similarly can make y sperm with sry
or without s or Y
thinking that the Red X chromosome comes
from the mother here this the father
then makes four kinds of babies
he makes XX babies that are normal
females and have ovaries
is makes X Y minus babies that don't
have soy and they have ovaries therefore
too
and he makes xx and XY animals that have
the sry transgene and therefore they
have testes and they're called called
males so this is really a two by two
with
two half of the animals being xx and
half of the animals being XY half of the
animals having soy and half the animals
without sry
the animals with our y of testes and
testicular secretions the animals
without us or I have ovaries and ovarian
secretions
and so if we find that a sex difference
in a trait goes along with whether the
animals have testes or ovaries so if the
gonadal males differ from the gonadal
females then we say that the trait is
caused by hormonal effects but if on the
other hand the XX animals are different
from the XY animals then we say it's a
sex chromosome effect not dependent on
the gonads not dependent on the type of
gonadal secretions
so here's an experiment a simple
experiment of a sex difference male mice
are larger than female mice
and we weigh the animals at day 21 and
the day of weaning and we're measuring
body weight and there are four groups
they are the either XX or XY and they
have ovaries called gonadal females
or they have testes the black bars
called genital males and you can see it
weaning there's not much difference
among the four different groups
but if we wait 24 days thereafter and
let puberty happen
the hormones kick in and the animals
with testes the two male groups way more
than the animals with ovaries
and that suggests that body weight is
predominantly caused by gonadal
secretions
but in addition to that the animals that
are x x are slightly larger there's a
slight effect of sex chromosomes the XX
animals are slightly larger than x y
so assuming that the animals are
the sex differences caused predominantly
by hormones we do a classic endocrine
experiment which is to take out the
hormones to see if the sex difference
goes away
this is a paper in collaboration
um between lab and Karen Ruiz at UCLA
and the animals are weighed at two and a
half months of age
which is the zero week of the experiment
and the animals that are have testes way
more than the animals with ovaries after
you remove their gonads on that day four
weeks later the sex difference has
disappeared
and uh showing that the effect the body
weight effect was sex differences caused
predominantly by gonadal hormones but
then something unusual happens which is
that over a period of some months the ex
the animals that have two X chromosomes
are bigger and fatter than the animals
with
um that are X Y if you put them on a
high fat diet the livers become very
fatty except that happens mostly in the
XX animals not in the X Y animals so
body weight and and body fat here is a
sex chromosome effect in the absence of
the gonads
summary here is that with the gonad it's
intact animals with testes called males
are larger so the two blue animals are
larger than the two red animals the red
animals being the animals with ovaries
but in addition to that the XX animals
are slightly larger than x y if you take
out the gonadas then the two XX animals
become much larger and fatter than the
animals that are XY
so then we use a second model which was
um discovered by Eva eichert at the
Jackson Laboratories and this is a model
that has four different genotypes shown
here as XX
y x y and XO
and they they either have two X
chromosomes or they have one X
chromosome or they have a y chromosome
or not but the number of X and Y
chromosomes are relatively independent
so we do the same experiment at two and
a half
um months of age we weigh the animals
before we take out the gonads and the
two male groups weigh more than the two
female groups
as uh as before a month after
taking out the gonads these sex the sex
difference goes away confirm the
hormonal nature but then if over a
period of months animals with two X
chromosomes whether they have a y
chromosome or not
are heavier and fatter than the animals
with One X chromosome showing that the
sex chromosome effect is an X effect and
so now we're getting somewhere as we're
trying to narrow down
the um where the genes are that are
causing these effects we know it's a an
X chromosome effect uh this these models
now that have been applied in numerous
models of disease
and there are many diseases that are
influenced by sex chromosome effects
showing that the sex differences in
these diseases are in part caused by sex
chromosomes not by gonadal hormones now
I shouldn't say not by gonadal hormones
in in most or all cases there's also a
gonadal hormone effect so the sex
difference is a mixture of our model and
sex chromosome effect and that's the
typical case
and so there are numerous diseases that
have been studied in many different
Laboratories
and so forth there's been about 80
papers published and then using the X Y
star or other models we can ask well of
these sex chromosome effects how many
are caused by the X chromosome and
there's a list of 12 and this is in fact
not a exhaustive list but many of the
sex chromosome effects are are actually
caused by the number of X chromosomes
not by the number of Y chromosomes so
now we would like to know okay precisely
what are the genes causing these sex
chromosome effects
um and as I said before we know
the what hormones are the primary agents
of sexual differentiation causing the
hormonal effect
but now we want to find the new the new
testosterone the new agents in the sex
chromosome category that are causing uh
these effects
now X inactivation
is actually a a process that makes the
two sections more equal
because
females have two extra chromosomes and
males have One X chromosome by shutting
off transcriptionally silencing One X
chromosome the X inactivation process
makes females have one active X
chromosome any cell each somatic cell
just like an x x y cell so xx and XY
cells generally have one active X
chromosome
but then many genes can escape this
excellent activation process this is a
and others
mapping the human X chromosome for
sexual bias
and the these are different tissues of
from the gtex Consortium and different X
genes mapped along the X chromosome here
and so each column is one gene expressed
in different tissues and the red squares
are the genes that are expressed higher
in XX than x y
the blue squares are genes that higher
XY than x x
and you can see that there are quite a
few genes that are sexually
unequal in their expression and there
are on the non-seudos orosomal part of
the X chromosome there are genes that
escape X inactivation and others there
are about 25 percent of the genes are 23
percent
are expressed higher in XX than x y
that's the second class of of genes that
cause sex differences that I mentioned
earlier
and so uh so and this sorry this slide
shows
that four genes in mice that are are
um some of the main genes escaping X
inactivation they're encoded by the X
chromosome
and here are two genes cadium-6a and
cadine 5C which are histone in
methylasis and you can see that in the
four core genotypes the two x x animals
either males or females Express cadem 6A
higher than the two x y animals and this
is in I believe in adipose or liver I
forget which
and these escapees have this pattern
where they're higher in XX than x y and
can therefore lead to sex differences
um our experiment to prove which of the
X genes are causing the sex difference
in adipose or other tissues is to take
an XX female
and then knock out one copy of the x
escape e
in in one group of animals so one group
of animals is plus minus for the gene of
Interest let's say KDM
5C and one group is a wild type and has
two copies of Canadian 5C and so now
we're varying Cadence 5c
one versus two copies instead of varying
one versus two copies of the of the X
chromosome
and and that's schematically shown here
and we can compare the protein levels to
confirm that in fact
the um uh knockout works okay when you
um reduce the dose of Canadian 5c from
two to one from two to one
um the the body weight of the animals
goes down just as as if you were
comparing x x and x y or xx and XO that
is the dose of cadine5c explains much of
the sex chromosome effect
and this then identifies KTM 5c as an
agent of sexual differentiation because
of its inherent sex difference in dosage
this is also true for body fat animals
with two versus one copy of KTM
um k95c here show differences in body
fat and it doesn't matter whether
they're on a child diet or a high fat
diet get the same dosage effect of KTM
5c
so our Pathway to discovery of the sex
chromosome effects was first of all to
use the four core genotypes model to to
find that XX and X Y animals were
different even if they had the same kind
of gonad
then to compare xx and EXO animals to
find an X dosage effect or an X
chromosome effect
and then to manipulate the level of one
specific Gene
um all by itself keeping all the other
factors constant so there this this
these experiments have done been
performed uh several times over
the example I've been using was done in
Karen rui's lab in collaboration with us
and
um showing a dosage effect of the of the
histone dementlase
Acadian 5c
um causing differences in metabolism and
in differentiation of Adipose cells
in other labs
um the similar kinds of experiments have
been done in the lab of Rondo law school
at UCLA
they study um
experimental autoimmune
encephalomyelitis a model of multiple
sclerosis in which a mouse is injected
with an auto antigen a myelin protein
mix
and a immune reaction is induced and
then the animal shows a multiple
sclerosis of like disease so over time
the animals injected on Day Zero
and the end then the clinical score here
is mapped in which a healthy animals
gets a very low score and an unhealthy
or
um animal that has has difficulty
walking and riding itself gets a high
clinical score and in and these are
comparing animals that both have testes
these are this is the four chord
genotypes model and the XX animals uh do
worse and stay worse than the XX animals
so in this case
being XX is a animal worse than being x
y and you can see different levels of
inflammation also caused by sex
chromosome complement
then the the Vasco group knocked down
the another X escapee KDM 6A
in CD4 positive T cells and showed that
this um
uh
change the disease profile as well so
the sex chromosome effect is explained
in part by the dosage of KDM 6A in T
cells using this was a conditional
knockout using a creelock system so
here's the same kind of clinical
experiment the animals injected with the
autoantrogen early in the experiment
and here the clinical score goes from
healthy to unhealthy the wild type
animal gets sick and stays sick the
disease with a high disease level
whereas the conditional knockout of KTM
6A in the T cells protects the animal
so in this case a high dose of cadence
6A is is harmful and a low dose of
cadmium 6A is protective
in the disease within the T cells
specifically
third example of this kind of approach
was done in the laboratory of Dina dubal
at UCSF investigating Alzheimer's
disease
so in Alzheimer's disease the male
mortality is greater than the female
mortality in human populations
and this lab uses a model of Alzheimer's
in which a humanized
amyloid precursor protein is inserted
into the Genome of the mouth
and in Wild type mice
you can see on the left side here that
if you're comparing two animals that
have the
humanized Gene inserted into their
genome and this kills the animals
prematurely and the females
survive better than the males
in Wild type animals ex-females versus
XY males in the four core genotype the
animals with two X chromosomes whether
they are males ganana males or ganado
females
do better than animals that are X Y
showing this sex chromosome effect
and in the X Y star model where you're
independently manipulating the number of
X and Y chromosomes animals with two X
chromosomes either X X or X Y do better
than animals with One X chromosome
showing that it's an X dosage effect
they then manipulated again the
cadium-6a gene which is escapes exact
activation and is expressed higher in x
x than x y
so in one level in one experiment they
manipulated the levels of KDM 6A in an
in vitro experiment by knocking down KTM
6A with
um with interfering RNA
um the KDM 6A here is protective so the
knockdown these animals are the
knockdown group have low levels of
Acadia 6A
and there and there and they have a have
higher levels
of toxicity to the a beta molecule
when KDM 6A levels are low whereas the
wild type animal that gets scrambled
um
interfering rnas at less neurotoxicity
showing a protective effect of
cadmium-6a
in another experiment the dubal group
overexpressed KDM 6A in hippocampus
using a lentivirus and injected into the
hippocampus of live animals
and they show that this then increases
the level of expression of kdh6a in
hippocampus and in a learning Paradigm
the animals that are carrying the
Alzheimer's allele the humanized app
allele
um the the XY animals which normally
have low levels of cadium-6a if you
increase the k26a you increase their
ability to learn
and that shows a protective effect of
the KTM 6A in an animal that is normally
has a low level of expression
another example is Acadia 6A effect on
bladder cancer in the laboratory of Sean
Lee who was at this time at Harvard
and um in uh in this case a drug is
injected into animals that induces
bladder cancer and reduces survival
and in the four chord genotypes
experiment animal
the female groups that is the animals
with ovaries
live longer than the male groups showing
a hormonal effect
um
but in addition the in the both group in
both sexes the XX animals do better than
the XY animals and they live longer
showing a sex chromosome effect
when they knocked down KTM 6A so here's
the animal an XX animal that has normal
levels of cadium-6a and is wild type if
they if they eliminated KTM 6A which is
normally higher in XX than x y
then the animals did not live a long
time showing that the KDM 6A was
protective in this case
and the final example comes from it's
actually a y chromosome effect not a an
extra chromosome effect
and it's from the lab of Mansura egbali
at UCLA and they study pulmonary
hypertension and other cardiovascular
diseases
pulmonary hypertension affects women
much more than men it's untreatable and
it's often a fatal disease
and this a pulmonary hypertension can be
induced in mice by putting them in a
hypoxic chamber in a low oxygen level
for several weeks
and at the end of several weeks you can
measure among other things the pressure
in the right ventricle
so in the four chord genotypes
experiment the animals with two X
chromosomes have higher pressure than
the animals with
X and Y chromosome
showing that X Y is protected in some
way
to determine whether this is an X or a y
effect they use the XY star model
and here this shows that animals with a
Y chromosome either x x y or XY do
better have lower pressures than animals
that don't have a y chromosome either XX
or XO showing this in X chromosome an x
a y chromosome effect
and subsequent experiments have led to
the discovery that this the gene uty on
the Y chromosome that is protecting
Nails in this mouse model
so our Pathway to discovering new agents
of sexual differentiation
has been to study the inherent
inequality of XM XY cells starting out
with the four core genotypes and the XY
star models
and
um
noting that both sex chromosome and
hormonal effects usually operate
together on the same traits but their
interactions are not well studied and
recent Studies have identified and
discovered new agents of sexual
differentiation KTM 6A KTM 5C and uty
this now opens up the study of mechanism
mechanisms Downstream from the action of
these genes
so this these experiments have been
highly collaborated collaborative and
here's a list of some of our
collaborators
at UCLA and of course we got the mice
originally and learned from Paul
Burgoyne who sadly passed away last year
and um both Paul and Robin level badge
have been a tremendous collaborative
collaborators and colleagues
and we thank the NIH and other agencies
for support thank you very much